[Musique]
louis xii occupe une situation
particulière dans l'histoire de france
il règne une époque charnière entre le
moyen âge et la renaissance après avoir
chassé les anglais les rois valois hf de
rassembler les provinces et prépare le
terrain pour le plus célèbre d'entre eux
françois 1er issu de la maison d'orléans
branche cadette de la maison des valois
louis d'orléans futur louis xii doit
attendre la mort accidentelle de son
cousin charles 8 de huit ans son cadet
pour enfin régner
on connaît peu ce roi qui poursuivit les
guerres d'italie lancé par son
prédécesseur et parvint à donner au
royaume de france
une dimension et une unité qui n'avait
encore jamais connu
c'est quelqu'un qui n'est pas forcément
non plus ostentatoire dans sa façon de
parler d'exprimer une idée de montrer
son son pouvoir
ça reste malgré tout un très très grand
guerrier et et tout le son règne est
essentiellement axée sur cette image
justement de prince militaire avec des
véritables qualités et avec une ambition
aussi beaucoup plus grandes que celles
qu'on lui laisse penser c'est à dire
celle d'un une ambition impériale très
très marqué les défaites de la quatrième
guerre d'italie et réduire à néant ses
conquêtes mais il sut rattachée à la
france des provinces qui ne lui était
pas encore acquise comme la bretagne
il fut aussi un grand administrateur et
s'attela à réformer le pays dans tous
les domaines d'impôt justice clergé il
s'attache à faire régner la paix à
l'intérieur du pays en proie aux luttes
intestines ce qui permis un essor
économique sans précédent et un
accroissement important de la population
se son règne la france de vingt états le
plus puissant d'europe
il fut nommé père du peuple lors des
états généraux de 15 106 et à la
révolution française
les révolutionnaires le prirent comme
exemple d'un souverain modéré par
opposition au monarque absolu dont il
voulait se débarrasser c'est à cette
époque aussi que les femmes commencent à
jouer un rôle important au sein du
royaume avec anne de beaujeu fille de
louis 11 et régente jusqu'à la majorité
de son frère charles ou 8 et anne de
bretagne duchesse d'une province très
convoité qui épousera successivement
charles 8 et louis xii si françois
premier demeure dans les esprits comme
le roi qui a fait venir les artistes
italiens de la renaissance à la cour ce
mouvements esquissés souchard le 8 se
poursuit sous louis xii
grand amateur d'art seconde et par son
épouse très attirés par le luxe et les
richesses
[Musique]
louis d'orléans futur louis xii n'est en
14 162 emplois
il est le fils de marie de clèves et de
charles d'orléans le prince poète auteur
d'une oeuvre immense et de pièces
politique en anglais et bien charles
d'orléans est un poète avant toute chose
on le connaît comme un poète mais il est
aussi le fils de louis premier le duc
d'orléans où il premier qui est le frère
du roi charles ciss le roi fou charles
ciss et louis premier donc à ce fils
charles charles d'orléans qui va être
prisonnier pendant la guerre de cent ans
prisonnier des anglais à la bataille
d'azincourt en 14 115 transporté en
captivité en angleterre et deux mois il
s'était marié sa première femme n'avait
pas les moyens de payer sa rançon ou la
deuxième non plus et il va rester
prisonnier en angleterre pendant 25 ans
25 ans un quart de siècle
alors comment vous situez va-t-il tuer
le temps plus simplement en écrivant des
rondeaux des deux ravissants poèmes
qu'ils ont inscrits dans les grands
auteurs de la littérature française et
puis au bout de 25 ans il est libéré il
va rentrer en france
c'est un vieux monsieur maintenant et il
va épouser à 67 ou 68 ans la jolie
petite marie de clèves kiala 14 ans et
ils vont avoir un fils un fils qui va
devenir le roi louis xii
son père meurt en 14 265 alors qu'il n'a
que trois ans le nom orléans est donnée
à la branche cadette
ils sont à la fois descendants des
capétiens apparenté à la branche
régnante est considéré quand même comme
des rivaux dangereux par cette branche
régnante
le roi de france louis 11 prend alors
sous sa tutelle ce petit neveu d'orléans
et lui fait donner une éducation très
sévère en l'absence d'héritier mâle il
veut garder le contrôle sur l'enfant et
se promet de le marier à sa fille jeanne
surnommé l' estropiés que l'on pense
stérile en 14 276 alors que louis n'a
que 14 ans le roi fait célébrer cette
union
après avoir obtenu une dispense du pape
sixte iv puisque les deux jeunes gens
sont cousins il pense ainsi scellé
l'extinction de la branche d'orléans
après cette union
chacun des époux retourne ses
occupations louis devenus adolescents
même bientôt une vie de plaisirs et de
débauche
tandis que jane se consacre à la prière
et aux oeuvres charitables
elle sera canonisé en 1950
[Musique]
louez 11 meur en 483 louis d'orléans
alors âgé de 21 ans espère bien devenir
réjean auprès du petit charles qui n'en
a que 13 mai il échoué c'est la
princesse anne de beaujeu
ce rennais du nouveau roi qui est
désigné par les états généraux de tours
ils suivent en cela le souhait exprimé
par le roi louis 11 sur son lit de mort
anne de beaujeu va exercer la régence de
14 à 181 3 à 14 100 91
avec son mari elle va mettre un terme à
la guerre folle révolte sanglante qui
oppose le duc françois ii bretagne le
roi rené de lorraine et louis d'orléans
entre autres seigneurs au jeune roi et à
la régente c'est la bataille de
saint-aubin-du-cormier en 14 188 qui en
marquera le point final
louis d'orléans est fait prisonnier il
est incarcéré pendant trois ans charlot
8 le délivrera lorsqu'il accédera au
pouvoir
[Musique]
grassi par charles ou 8 devenu roi louis
d'orléans suit son cousin en italie où
il tente vainement de s'emparer du duché
de milan
ils estiment avoir des droits sur ce
territoire
dans la mesure où valentine visconti
était la fille de joe galeazzo visconti
seigneur de milan et d'isabelle de
france c'est la première guerre d'italie
l'europe à cette époque a profondément
changé pour la france l'ennemi n'est
plus le roi d'angleterre qui ne possède
plus que calais mais l'archiduc
d'autriche des guerres d'italie marque
le début de l'affrontement entre valois
et habsbourg qui vont bientôt prendre
possession de d'espagne et tente
d'unifier leurs empires en s'emparant de
l'italie mais dans ce cas les français
se verrait encerclé par la puissance
autrichienne charlot 8 par de grenoble
et franchit le col de montgenèvre le 2
septembre 14 294
les français avancent rapidement louis
d'orléans mettant en déroute les
aragonais à rapallo près de gênes et
continue en direction de naples florence
est prise le 17 novembre et naples
occupée le 22 février 14 995 le futur
louis xii reste lui à nova arrêts hélas
pour lui il va se retrouver encerclés à
siéger et il va le voir s'enfuir dans
les conditions absolument misérable est
rentré en france il repartira plus tard
en campagne d'italie mais la première
campagne pour lui s'est mal terminée
ludovic sforza dit ludovic le more
encerclent la ville et assiègent les
français qu ils évacueront en octobre 14
charlot 8 rêve de revanche mais louis
lui en veux de ne pas l'avoir délivrée
plus vite de novare et et d'avoir fait
alliance avec ludovic sforza ennemi
héréditaire d orléans il s'éloigne de la
cour et refuse de repartir en italie
il doit se plonger dans des études
ouvrages de droit en particulier qui lui
permettront d'administrer et de réformer
plus tard le royaume
[Musique]
e
charles ou huit meurt le 7 avril 14 198
au château d'amboise en se heurtant la
tête
olemps tôt d'une porte il n'a pas
d'enfant pour lui succéder cet accident
stupide ou voit donc la voie où trône
pour louis d'orléans
il a 35 ans il montre dès le début son
désir de réconciliation par ses célèbres
mots le roi de france ne venge pas les
injures faites au duc d'orléans
lorsqu'on est assis sur le trône le plus
élevé eh bien on doit oublier toutes les
mesquineries on ne doit pas se venger de
toutes les avanies que l'on n'a reçu sur
le chemin du pouvoir
toutes les possessions de la famille
d'orléans font désormais partie du
royaume de france louis xii veut à
présent divorcé de son épouse jeanne
qu'il a toujours négligé pour épousé
anne de bretagne
la veuve du défunt roi ainsi la bretagne
sur intel annexé au royaume
pour obtenir du pape alexandre 6
l'annulation de son mariage il fait du
valentinois un duché qu'il donne à césar
borgia fils du pape ainsi le mariage
peut-il être concluants 14 199 et le
pape devient-il un allié des français
dans la deuxième guerre d'italie
[Musique]
louis d'orléans hérite des droits des
valois sur le royaume de naples estimons
avoir également sur le duché de milan
widows va reprendre cette politique
expansionniste va pas aller directement
à naples il va aller à milan milan c'est
plus rapide il ya moins de problèmes de
diplomatie et puis c'est surtout parce
qu'il a des droits
à cause de sa grand-mère valentie de
visconti et le cil la première tentative
de deux conquêtes de milan est un échec
la seconde est une véritable réussite
gènes se donne aussi du coup au roi de
france qui dit jeanne dit aussi l'île de
corse c'est un territoire qui devient de
plus en plus important
il s'est déjà rapprochée du pape ils
signent le traité de blois avec la
république de venise le 2 février 14 199
puis le traité de lucerne avec les
cantons suisses
enfin conclu des accords avec le roi
henri viii d'angleterre et le futur roi
de castille philippe de habsbourg
ludovic sforza a dit ludovic le more duc
de milan se trouve isolé ludovic sfar a
été sans doute celui qui a découvert
léonard de vinci ou qui est qui a
protégé un nombre considérable
d'artistes et qu'il avait une cour
absolument magnifique qui rendait très
jaloux les rois de france
donc c'était une proie les français
passent à l'attaqué en juillet 14 299 et
ludovic doit se réfugier au tyrol
gène est également pris par les français
[Musique]
louis xii rentrer dans son royaume
laissant sur place son général
condottiere tribune chez mais ludovic
sforza parvient à lever une armée il ya
reprendre milan en mars qu'un sens
le roi de france envoie la trémoille et
georges d'amboise reconquérir le duché
ludovic sforza n'ayant pas payer ses
mercenaires
ceux ci refusent de combattre et vont
même jusqu'à livrer leurs chefs à novare
et le 10 avril 15 cents
[Musique]
ce prince italien qui avait le tort
d'être trop riche trop beau trop associé
l'image artistique dont rêvait les
princes français a connu une fin un peu
triste dans un château français ludovic
le more est fait prisonnier il mourra en
captivité au château de loches le 27 mai
15 108 le duché de milan est de nouveau
aux mains des français louis xii regarde
maintenant vers naples
il obtient l'accord du pape qui
reprochent au roi de naples de s'être
allié au turc
il signe avec le roi d'aragon le traité
de grenade qui définit le partage du
royaume à conquérir
[Musique]
devant cette double offensive le roi de
naples capitule le 26 septembre 15 cents
mais en 15 100 de un conflit éclate
entre la france et l'aragon à propos des
territoires occupés le pape meurt en
15/100 3 et louis xii ne peut pas
compter sur son successeur
les français essuie défaite sur défaite
et on février 15 904 par l'armistice de
lyon louis xii renonce au royaume de
naples au profit de ferdinand d'aragon
[Musique]
si woods aux repères le royaume de
naples au bout de deux ans enfin sa
partie du royaume de naples le duché de
milan et le la république de gênes il va
la conserver pratiquement pendant tout
son règne et cette domination pendant
près de 15 ans de ces territoires vont
apporter énormément d'argent à la france
et c'est ce qui va permettre à louis xii
justement de pratiquer une politique
plus d'impôts plus modérée en france et
les italiens payant toutes les guerres
c'est le traité de cambrai signant 15
108 qui met le feu aux poudres
il comprend une disposition publique une
alliance entre le roi de france et
l'empereur maximilien d'autriche ouverte
au pape au roi d'angleterre d'aragon et
de hongrie en vue de combattre les
ottomans mais il comprend aussi une
disposition secrète qui envisage la
formation d'une ligue contre venise dont
les territoires sont déjà attribuées par
avance
le roi de france récupèrerait à l'issue
de cette campagne le duché de milan tant
convoité
la guerre éclate en mai 15 109 après le
refus de fanis de céder à un ultimatum
du pape qui excommunie la république
les troupes françaises commandées par le
roi en personne battent les vénitiens le
14 mai à la bataille
dania d'elle et prennent possession des
villes lombardes qui lui reviennent ses
alliés font de même mais le pape jules 2
est inquiet des avancées française il 24
février 15 110 il lève l'excommunication
de venise et les troupes papa les
vénitiennes s'allient pour chasser les
français d'italie en mai 15 111 louis
xii prend bolen convoque un concile à
pise pour destituer le pape qui convoque
un autre concile à latran et excommunie
les membres du concile de pise
le conseil de de pise est une réaction
presque obligatoire du roi de france
jules 2 qui a succédé à alexandre 6 à
d'abord été très favorable français
forcément parce que il devait son
élection au roi de france est à
l'abandon de jean rue d'amboise qui
concourait aussi à la vente sur le
problème c'est que jules 2 a très vite
montré ses ambitions et à l'upr de plus
en plus de cette puissance française et
donc en 15 100 9 après la victoire de
louis xii contre les vénitiens et qui
faisaient de louis xii le prince le plus
puissant d'europe
eh bien il va créer une ligue à sainte
ligue contre le roi de france et a mené
tous les ennemis du roi de france avec
lui pour chasser louis xii d'italie le 5
octobre 15 11 le pape forme la sainte
ligue avec l'espagne venise l'angleterre
et les cantons suisses la france est
bien seul
à partir de là les français vont perdre
petit à petit tous les territoires
qu'ils avaient conquis en quinze sont
douces maximilien ce forza est placé sur
le trône de bilan le 6 juin 15 113
ils perdent la bataille de novare et
contre les suisses les anglais attaquent
à calais les suisses en bourgogne
avant ce jusqu'à dijon et les aragonais
avance en navarre
windows a perdu toute l'italie bien
qu'il refuse de signer le traité de
dijon qui l'obligent à abandonner le
duché de milan et toutes ses conquêtes
[Musique]
c'est françois 1er qui poursuivra
l'aventuré soucieux lui aussi de
regagner l'héritage de valentine
visconti
[Musique]
louis avait donc été marié par louis 11
à sa fille jeanne la boiteuse houle
estropiés seconde fille du roi après
anne de beaujeu qui est devenue régente
à la mort de son père l'acte de
fiançailles a été signé dès 14 164 louis
ayant deux ans et jeanne est en appel
baptisé le roi n'ayant pas de fils il
voulait pouvoir former son éventuel
successeur
en quatorze 173 le petit dauphin
françois hammer il ne reste plus qu'un
seul héritier mâle lyons décident
d'établir le contrat de mariage à
jargeau entre la fillette âgée de 9 ans
et deux jeunes garçons âgés de 11 mai
jeunes et louis est un cousin leur
grand-père charles ciss et louis promis
d'orléans étaient frères ils ont besoin
d'une dispense du pape qui est accordée
par le pape sixte iv en 14 176 le
mariage est célébré au château de
montrichard le 8 septembre de cette même
année
lyon 11 n'y assiste pas puisqu'il
célèbre le même jour le mariage d'une
autre de ses filles marie avec lui
compte de narbonne gens de foi le
lendemain louis présente son épouse à la
population de blois où il réside et où
il est né puis chacun retourne à ses
occupations
si jeanne pieuse et aimante et triste de
voir son mari mener une vie de plaisirs
et de débauche
louis ne peut supporter cette femme dit
forme qu'on lui a imposée
louis 11 rappelle régulièrement son
gendre à ses devoirs et les deux époux
vivent ainsi unis et séparés durant sept
ans jusqu'à la mort du roi louis 11 le
30 août 14 à 181 3
oui refuse de subvenir aux besoins de sa
femme jusque là soutenu par son père et
c'est sa soeur anne qui lui verse une
rente pour qu'elles puissent mener un
train de vie digne de son rang
il faut dire que louis furieux de ne pas
avoir obtenu la régence il se lance dans
la guerre folle c'est l'expression d'un
d'un chroniqueur kiné qui parle d'une
guerre en fait une guerre sans espoir
parce que c'est toujours la même la même
histoire qui recommence ce sont les
grands féodaux qui s'opposent au pouvoir
royal comme on l'a vu avec louis 11 au
moment de la pra gris comme on le
reverra après avec la fronde sous louis
xiv et et à beaucoup d'autres moments de
l'histoire
à l'issue de la guerre folle louis
d'orléans est enfermé pendant trois ans
dans différentes forteresse jusqu'à ce
que charlie 8 le gracie lors de son
avènement à la mort de ce dernier en 14
198 louis xii monte sur le trône et
s'empresse de faire annuler son mariage
par le pape en prétextant qu'il n'a
jamais été consommé
ce que réfute son épouse jeanne a quand
même donné son avis elle a dit je sais
bien que je ne suis pas très joli mais
mon mariage a tout de même été consommés
en réalité ces protestations n'ont servi
à rien un procès se tient aux termes
duquel cette union qui aura duré 22 ans
et cassis par le pape alexandre iv
borgia ce qui est assez intéressant si
on regarde bien les détails c'est que
cet alexandre borgia faisait partie des
papes qui avaient des enfants et il
avait notamment un fils et ce fils a été
bien doté
c'était césar borgia et il a été très
bien doté par louis xii qui lui a offert
le duché du valentinois louis peut
épouser le 8 janvier 14 999 à nantes
anne de bretagne veuve de charles ix 8
ce qui est pour lui un moyen d'annexer
définitivement le riche duché de
bretagne
une clause du contrat de mariage entre
charles ou 8 et anne spécifié que la
reine devrait se remarier avec le
successeur de charles ou huit
en l'absence d'héritier mâle anne de
bretagne ne s'efface pas derrière son
époux elle sait très bien négocié son
contrat de mariage avec louis xii celui
qu'elle a en face d'elle est un ancien
allié dans la guerre folle il reconnaît
l'intégralité de ses droits sur la
bretagne
mais le pouvoir régalien sera exercée
par le roi de france qui prend le titre
de duc consorts
[Musique]
les époux vivent tableau à roanne va
apposer sa marque
elle est très cultivé et apprécient
l'art italien
elle fait réaliser dans la cathédrale de
nantes
le tombeau de ses parents qui porte les
symboles des quatre vertus prudence
force tempérance justice qu'elle
essaiera toujours d'observer on l'a
conservée d'elle de nombreuses lettres
et une importante bibliothèque
on lui doit un magnifique ouvrage les
grandeurs d'anne de bretagne un livre de
prières commandité à l'enlumineur jean
bourdy champ
sous le règne de louis xii le rôle des
femmes commencent à changer
la reine elle-même tête politique
secondes son époux dans l'exercice du
pouvoir
elle fait venir auprès d'elle des jeunes
femmes de bonne naissance à qui il fait
donner une instruction et ces dames
d'honneur bris bientôt par l'éclat de
leur intelligence
par la suite leurs maris comprirent que
les qualités de leurs épouses pouvait
jaillir sur eux et leur procurer
davantage de crédits dans la société
l'exemple du couple royal permet à
l'autre moitié du monde d'accéder à une
certaine reconnaissance anne de bretagne
remplit un rôle d' alter ego dans
l'imaginaire politique de l'époque une
offense faite à la reine devient un
crime de lèse majesté la reine de france
devient l'avocate du peuple et le
soutien de ses doléances
[Musique]
lorsque louis xii accès de pouvoir la
france sort d'une longue époque de
guerre intestine qui ont cependant
permis d'unifier un territoire qui
n'était jusqu'à présent qu'un assemblage
instable de province du ch et autres
possessions nobiliaire lyon avait bâti
un état fort et centralisé
non sans mal on peut rappeler la ligue
du bien public
révolte des seigneurs ligués contre lui
en 14 965 et une résurgence de la ligue
en 14 268 la guerre folle entre 14 185
et 14 988 à laquelle pris par louis
d'orléans future wii 12 ce qui lui valu
de passer trois ans en forteresse les
stigmates de la guerre de cent ans qui
s'achève en 453 sont encore présents
dans l'esprit de la population qui est
reconnaissante à son nouveau roi
d'éloigner les guerres intestines sous
le règne de louis xii
il n'y aura plus de conflit interne même
si au cours de la même période les
campagnes pour la conquête de l'italie
se succèdent
d'autre part le souverain réforme en
profondeur le système militaire
il fait abolir est réprimé les pratiques
des soldats de leurs officiers qui
pillaient et comme étaient toutes les
exactions possible dans les campagnes où
il était stationné
il faut préciser que souvent ils ne
percevaient aucune soldes désormais il
sera interdit aux soldats de quitter
leurs garnisons établis dans des villes
fermées et de se rendre dans les
villages avoisinants
tout manquement à la discipline
militaire sera sévèrement punis y
compris ceux commis par de hauts gradés
ce qui était inconcevable jusque là un
budget est créé pour rémunérer les
hommes
un nouveau règlement militaire est
institué ces sujets lui en sont
reconnaissants
ce bon roi maintient la justice et nous
fait vivre en paix il a ôté la pillerie
des gendarmes et gouverne mieux qu'aucun
juan fille prions dieu qui lui donne
bonne vie est longue
c'est cette paix intérieure qui va
permettre l'accroissement de la
population et le développement
économique du pays dans tous les
domaines
louis xii apporte des réformes et
structurent le pays unifié à son
avènement
il a déjà un projet de ce qu'il veut
faire pour le royaume durant sa longue
captivité de bourges
il a eu le temps de réfléchir aux
problèmes qui entravent l'évolution du
pays
on sait qu'il a lu le des offices de
cicéron et qu'il leur lit souvent il est
aidé dans son action par des ministres
dont ils écoutent attentivement les avis
on peut retenir parmi eux pierre de
rohan marichal de gier originaire du
duché de bretagne le maréchal de gl
cardinal dans boissons de créatures de
louis 11
ces deux personnes qui à 25 ans ont déjà
une grande puissance ce sont des cas des
deux grandes familles et lin et hommes
d'église l'autre était un militaire et
déjà maréchal a même pas 25 ans l'autre
et est aumônier du roi
c'est lui qui se porte au secours de
louis d'orléans lorsqu'il est assiégée à
novare et il est à ses côtés lors de son
avènement au 14 198
il l'accompagnera dans son entrée
triomphale à gênes en 14 298 il va être
son conseiller militaire dans ses
campagnes d'italie et il va l'aider dans
la transformation de l'armée
il aura le malheur de déplaire anne de
bretagne en faisant arrêter les bateaux
chargés d'effets précieux qu'elle
envoyait à nantes
cette puissance du maréchal de g sur le
plan militaire
même s'il n'a pas le pouvoir d'un
connétable puisque la charge de
connétable n'est pas ta tribu et va
gêner beaucoup de plus en plus son
mariage avec l'héritière d'armagnac
vallée en faire un des hommes les plus
riches de france et en 15/100 2,15 103
peut-être par jalousie sans doute même
et bien une cabale va commencer à se
créer et des rumeurs ont circulé comme
quoi agier auraient été susceptibles de
s'y louis xii était décédé et il était à
l'époque malades et bien d'interdire à
anne de bretagne de repartir sur nantes
c'est une rumeur rien d'autre même si
cette rumeur va dans l'historiographie
après devenir faits et réalités
mais ça c'est une autre histoire et bien
cette rumeur va va grossir de plus en
plus certains vont être choqués et anne
de bretagne louise de savoie et georges
d'amboise qui étaient tous intéressés
par la régence possible en cas de mort
du roi est bien vont s'allier contre le
maréchal de g il se retire donc dans son
château de sainte croix du verger en
anjou en dix ans la pluie m'a pris deux
bonnes heures pour me mettre aussi à
propos à couvert sous cette belle maison
les jalousies une brouille avec le
cardinal d'amboise désireux d'assurer la
région si le roi venait à mourir des
différends avec le parlement de paris
le conduisent à être jugé en 15 105 pour
crime de lèse majesté
anne de bretagne le fait condamner par
le parlement de toulouse considéré alors
comme le plus sévère de tout le royaume
il est privé de l'exercice de toutes
fonctions ainsi que de ses biens pendant
cinq ans et est enfermé au château de
dreux à l'expiration de sa peine il
obtient la permission de revenir à paris
et étape sous du crime de lèse majesté
mais il refuse de reparaître à la cour
et meurt en avril 15 113
l'autre personnage important de ce règne
et georges cardinal d'amboise dès son
accession au trône
louis xii le choisit comme ministre
principal on ne parle pas encore de
premier ministre aumônier du roi il est
confirmé à la mort de louis 11
il assiste à la consécration de louis
xii en la cathédrale de reims
le cardinal dedans bois êtes un homme
cultivé il est un grand mécène
archevêque de rouen elle est aussi un
homme riche il se concilie tout de suite
la faveur populaire en renonçant à
supprimer la taxe qui est élevé lors de
l'événement d'un nouveau roi c'est lui
qui va également obtenir l'annulation du
mariage entre louis xii et jeanne de
valois
il tentera un moment de se faire élire
pape sans succès
la question de la justice prend une
place très importante dans les débats
qui occupe cette période avec l ai posé
la question des lois et du contrat qui
unit le roi au peuple cette image de roi
justice et de louis xii qui est déjà
très présente pendant son règne et est
due essentiellement à une ordonnance
celle de mars 14 199
c'est une ordonnance de plus de 160
articles et qui va en tout cas et tenter
de réformer si ce n'est de réformer en
tout cas de redéfinir le rôle de chaque
individu dans la justice royale
on a beaucoup parlé de ça on a considéré
que c'était un acte fondateur est
essentielle
en tout cas par rapport à une nouvelle
idée de la justice royale
c'est cette justice n'est plus modérée
pendant longtemps la justice était
rendue selon des oiseaux râle la
rédaction du droit coutumier dans les
pays de droit nos écrits avaient
commencé en 14 154 avec l'édit de
montigny tour louis va prendre en 14 999
ce qu'on appelle l' ordonnance de blois
acte de réformation de la justice louis
xii danse dans cette ordonnance ne
faisaient que reprendre que beaucoup de
choses qui existait déjà
c'est un concept une sorte de deux
conglomérats de tous des toutes les
réformes qui avaient pu et exister d
précédemment
et alors certes il ya des exigences
beaucoup plus grande notamment contre la
corruption si on autorise la torture
toujours on essaye de la limiter à un
maximum
on essaye de limiter aussi les pots de
vin les tout ce qui est le népotisme à
l'intérieur même des parlements
les juges doivent se soumettre à un
examen pour prouver leurs connaissances
du droit des parlements sont créées pour
que la justice puisse être équitablement
rendu dans tout le territoire
ils exigent que pour chaque poste vacant
il lui soit présenté trois candidats
parmi lesquels il fera son choix
jusque là les baillis comme on appelait
les juges qui avaient acheté leur charge
était parfaitement ignorant et avait des
lieutenants qui faisait le travail à
leur place on exige qui les rémunère en
conséquence ce qui les conduit à ne plus
tant apprécié la fonction et à renoncer
d'eux mêmes à l'administration de la
justice
leroy exige des juges une parfaite
indépendance et qu'il jure sur
l'évangile de ne donner leur voix qu
jurisconsulte les plus éclairés et les
plus vertueux est il interdit que le
père le fils ou deux frères siège auto
même tribunal
parallèlement sont instituées des
gouvernements municipaux des magistrats
nommés par les habitants sont chargés de
veiller à la sécurité de la population
et à la bonne marche de la ville
le seigneur du lieu n'est plus seul
garant de la vie de ces sujets
enfin l' ordonnance de 15 110 impose que
la langue juridique soit 7 du peuple et
non le latin
le droit doit être dit désormais dans
les différentes langues de la france de
cette époque
c'est sous françois 1er que l'ordonnancé
de villers-cotterêts instituera
l'exclusivité du français dans les
documents relatifs à la vie publique du
royaume de france louis xii dès son
avènement renonce à la taxe qui était
prélevé sur le peuple en l'honneur du
nouveau roi par la suite il réduit la
taille impôts devenue annuelle en 14 239
pendant la guerre de cent ans d'un quart
et il promet de la réduire chaque année
autant de lui onze
elle était de 5 millions de livres
annuels louis xii la diminue à 1,5
million cela assure aussi la paix
intérieure
même s'il convient de dire que c'est en
partie grâce à ce que lui rapporte les
guerres d'italie qu'il peut se le
permettre
il ne faut pas oublier que les vaincus
devait payer de lourdes sommes au
vainqueur
sans parler des pillages il n'en est pas
moins vrai que fait nouveau le roi verse
aussi sa quote-part au trésor en
revanche ils se montrent beaucoup moins
généreux avec ses courtisans il dira à
ce sujet j'aime mieux faire rire mais
courtisans de mon avarice que de faire
pleurer mon peuple de mai profusion il
limite le luxe de ses vêtements réduit
des effectifs de la maison du roy exige
une tenue rigoureuse des comptes et
cherchent à vivre sur le domaine royal
plutôt que sur le revenu des oppositions
son peuple sans souvent lorsqu'il subit
sous le règne de son successeur françois
1er des surcharges d'impôt est de taille
un de ses représentants s'écria qu'on
nous remette seulement sous le règne de
ce bon roi louis xii le règne de louis
xii marque un tournant important
jusque là plus de 25 atelier monétaire
battait monnaie dans le royaume des
pièces de toutes sortes et de toutes
origines étaient échangés lors des
transactions et la population n'était
pas toujours au fait de leur valeur
exacte le roi décide donc d'unifier la
monnaie
des pièces d'or et d'argent d'abord
frappé à son emblème le porc-épic puis à
son effigie sont mises en circulation et
les lettres gothiques font bientôt place
aux lettres latines des privilèges
exagéré avait petit à petit été accordée
à l'université de paris
en 14 298 1 et 10 contre les abus dans
la scolarité provoque un conflit avec le
roi mais la renaissance est caractérisée
par une rénovation de l'enseignement la
tutelle du clergé cède progressivement
la place à celle de l'état un décret
royal de 14 9 198 créée à montpellier
le collège royal de médecine sous son
règne les lettres grecques et latines
furent brièvement enseigné dans cette
époque qui voit naître la réforme et
d'autres mouvements religieux dissident
lorraine de louis xii apparaît comme une
période de relative accalmie après les
massacres d'albigeois la répression
contre les vaudois adeptes de pierre
vaux death et avant la mise à mort de
protestants par françois 1er
il maintient l'ordonance appelé la
pragmatique sanction de bourges que son
successeur abolira par cette ordonnance
le roi s'affirme comme le gardien des
droits de l'église de france dont son
préambule la pragmatique sanction de
boues rouges dénoncent les abus de la
papauté
dans son premier article elle déclara
suprématie des conciles généraux sur le
saint siège
il imite les pouvoirs du pape la libre
élections des évêques et des abbés par
les chapitres et les monastères et
rétabli elle supprime les nominations
par le saint siège et son droit de
réserve
la royauté obtient de pouvoir
recommander ses candidats aux élections
des évêques louis xii ayant besoin de
l'appui de l'église de france pour
lutter contre jules 2 dans sa conquête
de l'italie
l'assemblée du clergé réuni à tours en
septembre 15 110 renouvelle
l'affirmation des libertés gallicane
elle récuse des guerres temporel du pape
contre les princes autorise des
campagnes royal et nationale contre le
vatican et annule tout excommunication
pontifical le concile gallican de pise
convoqué par louis xii dépose le pape
jules 2 pour divers motifs dont la
sodomie les prélats khiter ensuite milan
et se retirèrent à lyon où ils voulurent
continuer leur concile mais sans succès
en 417 et furent contraints de présenter
leurs excuses au pape
la pragmatique sanctions restera en
vigueur jusqu'à la signature par
françois 1er et léon 10 du concordat de
bologne en 15/100 16 dans le système
politique du royaume
on l'appelle états généraux des
assemblées exceptionnelle convoquée par
le roi pour traiter d'une crise
politique ou décider d'une aide
militaire ou fiscal
cette institution avait été créés en 13
102 par philippe le bel à partir de 14
cents 84 les ordres du jour était
préalablement établi sous forme de
doléances par les assemblées de province
chargé d'élire les députés elle été
recueillis dans ce qu'on appelle les
cahiers de doléances
pour la première fois en 14 284 il
rassemble des élus de tout le royaume et
de tous les corps sociaux
c'est la première fois que les paysans
sont représentés on entendra à cette
occasion un des députés philippe peau
développer une conception audacieuse du
gouvernement selon laquelle le pouvoir
politique appartient au peuple qui le
délègue au roi ce sont donc les états
généraux qui doivent organiser le
gouvernement et non la famille du roi
mineurs
louis d'orléans qui convoitait la
régence ne parviendra pas à vaincre les
ambitions de la soeur aînée de charles
anne de beaujeu les états généraux de 15
cents six sont parmi les plus importants
qui étaient détenus en france
le tiers état on devient un élément
important et forment la grande majorité
de l'assemblée
louis ne vois aucun danger à se mettre
pour ainsi dire à la disposition du
peuple
il en est adorée et le sait mais
prudemment il appelle les grands à
remplir les fonctions d'une chambre
haute
ils les éclairs sur tout ce qui touchait
au bien général de l'état et il adopte
ou rejettent ce que les députés ont
demandé
c'est au cours des états généraux de
tours de 15 106 que le projet de mariage
de claude defrance fille du roi avec le
futur charles quint est annulé louis xii
la fille ans alors à françois
d'angoulême futur françois 1er contre la
volonté de son épouse
cette union marquera une étape décisive
dans la réunion de la bretagne au
royaume de france
au cours de cette même assemblée
chanoine brico fit un éloge en bonne et
due forme du roi il loua pour le pardon
qu'il avait accordé à ses ennemis pour
la diminution des impôts les victoires
extérieur la réforme des abus dans les
tribunaux la répression des brigandages
militaires etc et finit en s'écriant
comment s'acquitteront vos sujets
daignez cyr accepté le titre de père du
peuple qu'il voudrait faire aujourd'hui
par ma voix
leroy quelques jours plus tard fille
répondre par son chancelier que le titre
de père du peuple était le don le plus
agréable qu'il pouvait recevoir de ses
sujets
la reine anne de bretagne meurt le 9
janvier 15 114 à blois
usé par les maternités et les maladies
louis xii est tellement affligé qu'ils
ne pensent qu'à rejoindre très vite son
épouse il dit avant que soient passés
l'an je serai avec elle et lui tiendrait
compagnie mais il veille à
l'organisation des funérailles et impose
à la cour lusage du deuil en vigueur en
bretagne ses funérailles sont d'une
grandeur exceptionnel elles durent
quarante jours comme elle le désire s on
coeur fut placée dans un reliquaire puis
transporté à nantes pour être déposée
dans le tombeau de son père françois de
bretagne pourtant louis se remarie le 9
octobre 15 114 à abbeville avec marie
d'angleterre la jeune soeur d'henri 8
pour sceller sa réconciliation avec le
roi d'angleterre
elle a 18 ans et lui 53 loup et accepte
de la suivre dans les festins et les
balles il désire aussi avoir un héritier
mâle et fait beaucoup de concessions
mais ils ne résistent pas à ce régime et
meurt d'une dysenterie le 1er janvier 15
cent quinze ans l'hôtel des tournelles à
paris il laisse le trône à son cousin et
gendre françois 1er qui l'a marié à sa
fille claude duchesse de bretagne pour
que le royaume reste ainsi unis
[Musique]
le tombeau de luis do they de son épouse
anne de bretagne est visible à la
basilique saint denis près de paris
c'est françois 1er qui le commande en
15/100 16
on retrouve la tradition gothique du des
arcades devenu un petit temple à
l'antique
le roi et la reine sont en prière sur la
terrasse supérieure
ces statues coucher représentent les
cadavres saisis dans les affres de la
mort en proie aux derniers espaces ils
sont réalisés d'après le moulage d'asir
des deux cadavres pendant l'embaumement
on peut même remarquer les points de
suture
les quatre vertus cardinales la justice
la force la prudence et d'intempérance
orne les angles du mausolée et les douze
apôtres sont disposés sous les arcades
[Musique]
et
après sa mort et en particulier au
xviiie siècle il devient le symbole
d'une monarchie modéré on va un peu et
de plus en plus oublier l'image
guerrière de louis doses pour ne
privilégier que l'image du roi modérée
du monarque français et est soucieux du
bonheur de son peuple et cette image là
bas poursuit va se poursuivre jusqu'à la
fin de la monarchie du régime
monarchique jusqu'à la fin du xviiie
siècle
pierre louis roederer homme politique
proche de la convention établit qu'une
filiation directe entre les réformes de
louis xii et la révolution française
sa vision modérée aurait mené la france
vers une monarchie plus juste et plus
stable et éviter la voix de
l'absolutisme senoglu écrit dans sa
lettre à louis xiv en 16 100 94
si le roi dit on avait un coeur de père
pour son peuple ne m est il pas plutôt
sa gloire à leur donner du pain l ai
fait respirer après tant de mots qu'à
garder quelques places de frontières qui
causent la guerre voltaire dans son
discours sur l'histoire de charles neuf
consacre quelques chapitres à faire les
louanges de louis xii
il admire ces réformes administratives
et sa défense de la pragmatique
sanctions on peut encore citer
montesquieu la france n'a jamais eu de
meilleurs citoyens à que louis xii le
cardinal d'amboise trouva les intérêts
du peuple dans ceux du roi et les
intérêts du roi dans ceux du peuple
alors que le panthéon est réservé pour
l'essentiel aux hommes de la révolution
le député charles lambert de béland
tente de faire valoir en février 1792
une exception pour le seul de nos rois
qui se soit montré le père du peuple
mais il ne parvient pas à les faire
entrer le bilan du règne de louis xii
est extrêmement favorable parce que il y
à ce titre de père du peuple
il y à ce titre cette phrase qui restera
dans l'histoire qui est un très beau
symbole qu'on peut appliquer beaucoup de
choses
enfin le roi de france oublie les
injures faites au duc d'orléans
et puis il y a cette image qui sera
restaurée à lors de du retour des
capétiens après la révolution française
qui fait que louis xii est quelqu'un qui
a compté dans l'histoire comme un roi
modéré tolérant et en même temps chef de
guerre puisqu'il a eu l'expédition
italienne qui ont plus ou moins apporté
à la france c'est michelet qui détruira
son image parlons de sa royale stupidité
il préférera encensé françois 1er
michelet va lui dresser un portrait
catastrophique en le traitant de vieux
d'imbéciles de malades de sénile de tous
complètement gouverné par part c'est par
son entourage notamment justement d'anne
de bretagne qui serait devenu plus
bretonne encore et qu'il cherchait qu'à
qu'à détruire la politique du royaume
est un homme complètement soumis à sa
femme ça c'est très très très mauvais au
19e et donc et l'image de louis xii va
jamais se relever de tout ça ça va être
repris puisque les paroles de michelet
sont quelquefois parole d'évangile pour
certains auteurs et ça va être pris
pendant un siècle et demi les pendant un
siècle et demi ce sera un roi médiocre
un roi sans aucun intérêt et aujourd'hui
depuis quelques années en tout cas on
cherche un peu à retravailler sur ses
personnages et on en découvre toutes les
finesses août la grandeur toute
l'intelligence silo rod louis xii a pâli
depuis le 19e siècle il n'en reste pas
moins le souverain d'une époque
charnière de l'histoire de france sous
son règne le royaume unifié se dote de
règles de gouvernement dans tous les
domaines proche de son peuple
il veille à son bien-être et parviendra
à maintenir l'unité nationale à
préserver la paix à favoriser
l'accroissement de la démographie et le
développement de l'économie en ayant
exporté la guerre en italie le royaume
de france si on ne regarde que que la
france est bien va prospérer pendant 12
13 ans aucune
aucune guerre va éclater sur le
territoire le commerce parce qu'il ya
tout un système d'alliances qui se fait
notamment avec l' empire peut se
développer grâce aussi au commerce avec
l'angleterre puisque l'angleterre 1
entrera en guerre contre la france qu'à
partir de 15 112 115 113 et donc par
conséquent pendant toutes ces années
empreinte 12 13 ans est bien de ce
commerce se développe aussi du drap de
la laine et des choses comme ça c'est
une vraie période de prospérité
c'est un vrai effort aussi sur leur
réorganisation par louis xii du domaine
royal pour le rendre plus rentable c'est
une grande masse hennissements aussi de
toutes les chambres des comptes avec une
surabondance de loi sur la monnaie sur
la fausse monnaie et des punitions de
plus en plus grande contre ces
falsificateurs il s'est efforcé de
rétablir une justice équitable pour tous
et d'assurer la sécurité de tous ces
sujets son attention aux doléances du
tiers état également lui valu le respect
des révolutionnaires
au cours de son règne les arts et
lettres commencèrent à connaître leur
essor
louis xii c'est aussi et surtout comme
grâce à ses conquêtes une ambition
impériale une volonté de faire de la
france un empire si ce n'est légitime
avec l'élection au moins légitime par
dieu et donc du coup et faire du roi de
france ce premier monarque chrétiens et
qui avec cette ambition messianique qui
excessivement importante elle et c'est à
cette époque c'est-à-dire de faire
croire il laissait croire que le roi de
france serait le dernier roi de
chrétiens qui irait à la conquête du
monde
convertir toutes les tous les infidèles
pour après donné toutes ses couronnes au
mont des oliviers au moment où le christ
sera ressuscité le peuple le regrettera
dans les années qui vont suivre
le royaume de france qui n'avait gardé
en paix va plonger dans les guerres de
religion et le sens fratricide
louis xii restera à jamais selon la
proposition des états généraux de 15 106
le père du peuple
[Musique]